two
what up what up what up it's may 4th
may the fourth be with you
[Laughter]
this is me with a lightsaber by the way
do you are you down with the may the
fourth be with you
am i allowed to be annoyed by that it's
one of the funniest things that's ever
happened in human history may the fourth
be with you like can you believe it that
there's a date that sounds like that
you know after all these shitty star
wars movies you'd think we could have
moved past that by now right now like
maybe if the trilogies were untouched
maybe if george lucas never went back
and added like a
a you know
a jam session in the canteen before all
that
you know the greatest scene in the movie
man what are you talking about
you should have been flogged for that
anyway it's may 4th guys thanks for
being here wait wait
you're telling me
you're not a fan
of uh
this bro i i swear to god i went and
swatched this movie
the director's cut or whatever and my
jaw was on the floor during the scene i
just could not believe
that this guy actually went back and
added this [ __ ]
[Music]
it made no sense even like in the
context of the film it didn't belong
there and it was just horrible
just a nightmare
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened in cinematic history i actually
think that
you know what what a [ __ ] nightmare
anyway
today's episode is sponsored by harry's
and stamps.com
love that
so we've got a great uh
today's wednesdays but we're back
because
wednesday it is
wednesday
man cause tomorrow at 10 a.m leftovers
is back
live
live
so don't miss it
lots to talk about this week oh yeah and
bobby lee and kalila are coming in on
friday
huge shows give it up let's go
and actually a really big show here
today
a really good one for a change finally
um you know there's a huge announcement
that is basically
[Music]
it's hard it's honestly going to be
really hard to
say it
i'm a little nervous to announce it
frankly
with all that's been going on on youtube
and in my career
we've been building up to this for a
long time
i'm both nervous excited a little sad
we're all here though
we got your back
well it affects you guys too
wait what it does
oh
but before we announce that there's some
stuff at the top of the show
that i want to talk about for example
this new spider-man video
what is this
[Music]
wait does spiderman swim
i never seen spiderman swim before he's
not supposed to spiders don't do well in
water i know that for a fact there was a
spider in the shower the other day and i
watched that [ __ ] struggling for
life that whole time i was in there and
it was just like little drops of water
too it wasn't even a lot
oh no
yo you little you little pieces of crap
stop splashing spiderman
[Music]
wait wait you got to mute the music i
think it's playing some damn spider-man
you're not supposed to go in the water
dude just to climb up buildings and [ __ ]
what the hell
you just released it dude these kids are
evil bro these are splashing his ass
he's drowning and [ __ ] look at him
what happened the water just gets stuck
in there you probably can't breathe you
can't really unzip it yourself you have
someone else he's suffocating yeah he's
drowning and these kids are splashing
his ass
pretty good
not as good as accordion spiderman but
pretty good
can i get a upside down kiss with that
thing on her no
holy smokes
well let that be a lesson spidey
no water
you know cobra tate
uh cobra the human trafficking irritate
people have been having a lot of fun
with cobra on the subreddit and i
thought it was worth bringing up because
you guys have been going
ham on your boy and this actually i
actually think this is a really good
resemblance this is kind of what i was
getting at when i said he looked
neanderthal
early man kind of thing you know yeah
but sloth i think is slothy at least has
a tender heart right oh yeah like he's a
sweetheart so in a way
i would place him as more dateable
he probably gets more [ __ ] to be
honest sloth
i can see that
i know that that somehow offends them
the most of all the things i say about
them
oh ethan when he gets news about another
lawsuit ethan cobra tate i don't want to
play with you anymore
that was pretty funny
like that
does cobra tate look like the harry
potter troll that's so true you guys oh
oh that's so true isn't it
yeah i see it
um does cobra tate look like
harry wait oh there's part two yeah yeah
what is this
they're just showing in comparison
yeah i got it i didn't i got it without
that
this is of course his uh timeless
classic i sleep in a racing car do you
i sleep in a big bed with my wife
that of course is from the great
seinfeld episode where uh milhouse's dad
simpsons
simpson symphony what i said
yeah seinfeld simpsons they're both
great
they both done it all right stop
laughing so that's funny
one of my favorite gags from this
instance of all time this scene is so
good so [ __ ] milhouse's dad gets a
divorce and he's having like a midlife
crisis and he buys himself a race car
bed
and uh
homer
but yeah basically that i mean you know
this was a real interesting one hide
your wives hide your women
i don't know what this character is but
i see the resemblance my goodbye golly
that is the naked mole rat from uh kim
possible
ah kim possible yeah it was an old
disney show
well the resemblance is uncanny yeah
you know like a
just like a
a flaccid penis really
uh cobra tate on the prowl for his next
sex slave
free what uh
do you do
hey do you ladies want some sparkling
water
yeah that's how he gets them
luckily that's not a very successful
approach no the sparkling water
generally not a huge pole
you don't have to think about it dude
this is of course the drake man date the
rich 6'4 guy with a jacuzzi
date the fat guy with a podcast who
shorts and
who's short and mouth breathes oh yeah
ladies
can i get a whoop whoop i mean hello
now i know i don't have a lot to offer
but i got more than that i won't put you
i won't put you into sex slavery
that's nice that's a huge bonus for me
that goes in the pro column yeah
that's a that's what we call a mega pro
you know
damn you guys went off the rails with
all these memes
so this is his brother right the tristan
wig dealer
he's like a traveling salesman yeah
yeah i see he went with kind of the i
think he went with like this one
nice
and there you have it that's basically
it
we actually have so much more cobra tate
stuff
but
we've got to um
pace ourselves
there was a whole thread
we found on twitter of like lots of dirt
because i haven't really gone in deep on
this cobra tate stuff but one there's a
clip of him being like the reason i i
moved to romania is because it's harder
to get charged with our word gear
pretty much what he
says yes my friends this man has said it
the red pill god
pull that one up let's watch that one at
least just a little tease
in the meantime the cobra tape memes
they keep coming here's another one
he's too smart to read y'all
reading books
is a very cheap way
to i guess entertain i wouldn't call it
entertainment because my brain is far
too advanced i'm too smart to read well
you can't be [ __ ] a real person
i need to sit there go smart people read
no i need action i need constant chaos
in my life to feel content i need to be
driving a supercar and [ __ ] fighting
[ __ ] a bunch of hoes and champagne
and going crazy i can't just sit there
oh
oh and the pirate on the boat yeah bro i
think the problem is that you're at like
a second grade reading level but the
pirate on the boat the boat is red huh
the pirate's beard is black he's like
man i'm too smart for this book and it
was used in a book huh
i'm way too smart for this book man i
already know my abc's [ __ ]
shit's way below me
on the boat like
just for life for people with slow
brains
bro you are such a [ __ ] loser
holy god
oh yeah there you go the fact that his
first example is clearly describing a
child's book about a pirate tells you
how long it's been since he's read a
[ __ ] book exactly
i was like is he describing moby dick
no no
no
uh cobra tate always parks in the
handicapped spot let's go dude
yes my boy
i always park in disabled base i'm not a
bad person but i'm a quick person most
people are slow and stupid i'm fast
there was no perk people in wheelchairs
trying to use this space in those 45
seconds to tell me to buy this so no no
one loses
but last time i uh
took one of these spaces someone goes
excuse me are you disabled i reply
their face was like
[Music]
well actually he might be but not in a
way that
that precludes you from walking
i mean if he's still reading second
grade
if he's still at a second grade reading
level he definitely
is disabled of some sort
you have that clip yeah i sent it all
right let's see let's watch this and
then we'll move on from cobra tate but
i'm telling you these memes keep on
coming and you guys seem to love it
based on all the memes we saw and it
deleted what cobra why are you deleting
videos
people era
explaining that in eastern europe it's
easier to get off on our charges and
saying this is 40 of the reason i moved
to romania the other 60 percent
uh the human trafficking is like they
barely even look at that
this is probably 14 of the reason i
moved to romania because in eastern
europe none of this garbage flies if
you're going to the police and say he
raped me back in 1988 because he should
have done something about it then if you
want to please say rape and yesterday
say okay if you've got physical evidence
all right so tv proof where'd it happen
okay let's go interview him right now
and if it wasn't really right oh we went
to the club we got drunk she agreed to
go back to my house we started having
sex and then we carried on having sex
and then we had sex and she didn't say
anything wrong and then she texted me
afterwards and i didn't text back and
now she's saying i raped her the police
were like okay she's an idiot bye but no
not in the west in the west you can tell
on that exact story you're still [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] in the west when people
say why didn't romania and i explain my
five reasons one of them is the metoo
era they go oh well you're a rapist i
say no i'm a [ __ ] rapist but i like
the idea of being able to just say to do
what i want i like being free and if
you're a man living in england or
germany or america or any of the western
world right now you've decided to live
in a country where any woman any eggs
any [ __ ]
[ __ ] who works at greg's you bought
pasty from at some point in the future
can destroy your life this me too era
[ __ ] subscribe now for exclusive
content
with great advice like move to romania
oh that's scary yeah this guy is
actually
it's it's very disturbing that this is a
real person out there with fans by the
way with fans
something i uh
just discovered uh right before the show
which i wish i had noticed the other day
because we were talking about him too
remember we were talking about mike
cernovich the other day yeah of course
there you go oh and great company no
not mike cernovich the gorilla mines
somehow these guys always all get
together
the best and brightest the world has to
offer absolutely
yeah
elon musk can be [ __ ] shouting out uh
cobra tate here in a minute on twitter
dropping like
us drop this drop a comment on this
video be like interesting
then it has an interesting perspective
yeah then it has 100 000 likes
all right one more one more fun thing at
the top of the show here
so keemstar you know friend of the show
he um
he has managed to take the l at the top
of every major subreddit right
like
this one is
let's see
thousand five hundred point what is the
oh enlightened centrism i see what's
happening here
i'm pro-life and i'm pro-choice
i would never want an abortion
personally but i feel women should have
the right to choose i cannot believe
this is about to get wait
that's a good take well except i mean
sure yeah he's pro-choice he's just he's
pro-choice he's just stupid yeah he's
pro-choice this the statement is i'm
pretty well of course he's pro-choice
otherwise he wouldn't be he wouldn't
exist if he was you know what i'm saying
if you
uh i'm saying yeah he has pro-choice
laws to thank i mean he
he was literally an orphan and i'm not
saying that to be insulting yes you are
it's ju no it's just a statement of fact
like he ended up in or his mom clearly
didn't want him and
you know if abortion was
i don't know where you're going with
this point i don't think you're making
the point you think you're if if
abortion was
right
yeah because it was legal yes daddy but
he that's why he likes it because he's
saying i'm alive i like my life you know
he says thank god
nasty it doesn't work it really doesn't
daddy
abort abort abort oh unlike oh that was
unintentional
now if you're asking me in the case of
keemstar i am pro i am pro-choice i am
yes
i'm actually pro-abortion
see at any term nine months abort it
hit the button post birth post natal
abortion actually
you can still abort him mom if you show
up it's not too late
we can still pull the plug
just saying
just saying
but i'm actually happy to hear that
keemstar is
pro-choice that's actually yeah whether
he realizes it or not yeah
uh
i think i
yeah
yeah yeah he's pro-choice
it's like a romeo julia yeah i mean the
top comment is that's what pro choice is
you flat-headed screwdriver
right
it's called pro choice for a region
[ __ ]
flatted screwdriver i've never heard
that before yeah muppet i like that
yeah well shout out to keemstar actually
for even though he said it in the
dumbest way possible he's right on the
money sure okay
where credit's due kind of absolutely
credit where it's still i mean he could
keemstar you never know what he's gonna
say i mean he could have come out
like let's go marger and taylor
gross right
yeah
but left all right let's get let's get
to my big announcement okay i've been
buttering you guys up
i'm trying to warm up the crowd here a
little bit
how am i doing so far
the mixed bag mixed bag
we did all right
was the was the abortion thing too much
well it just i was i was
i saw where you were going with it and
it immediately realized it it was
actually the opposite so
it wasn't it there was no good there
yeah to land that yeah i think it's more
of the chat it's just really antsy to
hear the announcement
since we mentioned it well that is true
that is true
that's big news yeah it's scary honestly
i'm scared i'm putting it off because
i'm nervous
maybe i can put it off more
you know
just scared and nervous too
yeah you guys heard okay
all right let me just first start by
leading into this by saying like you
guys might know uh
sekuno
it's like you know cause he's psycho
or psychic i guess he doesn't seem very
psycho he seems very mild-mannered and
nice
uh saikuno
was a big twitch streamer that moved to
youtube exclusive
uh along with this been happening a lot
like valkyrie was a big one ludwig was a
big one they've all come over
to youtube gaming
and um
the one thing they've been doing is
making these huge
video announcements
to announce their epic departure and i
think well here's valkyries they're all
um here's valkyries
um
let's just get an idea here
throughout my entire life
there's always been one bro
this video is in [ __ ]
2100k
i need all those pixels dead away they
make these like crazy over produced
videos i think this is something youtube
was like yo let's do this to get the
hype out so let's watch this
am i getting a claim for this [ __ ]
music
that's dead
it's royalty free to me but like just
has that vibe but
after the longest of days sorry i'm late
i just got back from work it's what
inspired me to keep going
the bags are my most difficult moments
this community has always been there for
me
these past few years
every aspect of my life has changed
of you all
i've been able to give back to others
especially those i love
[Music]
you know
her mom didn't seem that hyped for
getting a house yeah and you know what
everyone got a flex you know i
look
i bought my parents a house and i didn't
even [ __ ] get to flex it okay
and now i said it well now you are yeah
but i'm saying everyone got to do like
keys and [ __ ]
i did it okay
please clap for me
that's very cool of you
please clap for me okay
thank you
i just want a little [ __ ] cred here i
want you guys to think i'm a good person
it's not fair they get to flex all this
[ __ ] especially those i love
[Music]
mom's not even excited though you're
right
you've watched me grow my mom is like
it's too big if the house is too big i'm
gonna have to clean it all
she complains like crazy dude she
actually did
it's too big of a house it's just me and
your dad i'm gonna have to clean it all
what am i gonna do with this backyard i
can't do gardening back here
she loves it now by the way okay that's
good yeah but that's just what i was
dealing with
dubrick you know at first since i
haven't talked about this before
my parents wanted that to buy them a
[ __ ] trailer home
it's like a modified home they're like
trailers
and um it's was in newberry park and set
in like a woody kind of in the woods
sure
and i was like why the [ __ ] do you guys
want to live here
and it was during and there was like
huge wildfires going on i was like this
whole place is gonna
burn down besides the fact that why do
you wanna live in a trailer park i'll
buy you a house
and show she's she's very upset because
i'm not buying that house you know it's
just
it's ridiculous well the next summer
that whole [ __ ] place burned to the
ground oh no way yep
oh my god well you
made the right call i guess
it's just so weird
my mom is just such a lunatic but we
love her for that
i mean i could see the people living in
the woods no but like
in a trip she's in a trailer park and
like it's just it wasn't
if it's the one i'm thinking of i'd know
what you're talking about i used to ride
bikes through there
it is really beautiful there it is very
beautiful but i just didn't i didn't get
the whole thing
but there you have it so uh continuing
on the person i am today
[Music]
and i'm so excited to keep moving
forward
it's time for the next chapter
are you ready for something new
damn bro you got me hyped a f right now
so there you have it
and then the new one
which was by saikuno
um
this one was [ __ ] epic bro
is it in 25k is it is it pushing the
boundary of
pixels let's see i believe that's just
oh bro take this [ __ ] offline
shut him down
cancel the partnership youtube
so
saikuno uh just recently moved and he
also made a trailer that was like
bro and first of all no hate obviously
sweet guys both of them love them
was very dramatic and i was
just really crying the whole time
because
well
it's been a good run that's the name of
his video
damn bro
[Music]
oh [ __ ] we're in his eyeball this is
where it all started
in a tiny shed in my parents backyard
[Music]
i never planned on becoming a streamer
i just wanted to play some games and
amber all like i'm sorry but
this is powerful i know this is really i
had to pause to collect myself
he used to play in his back in his
parents shed y'all
yeah
yeah
and make some friends
and i did
[Applause]
powering up
i started off playing league look at it
bro at least pretend like you're playing
is he's just not even moving let's see
tho let's see those
actions per minute
right what the hell are you doing you're
not even moving your damn clicks
yeah just playing lead
then
minecraft valerian you see this lobster
among us
gta you know you have 24 hours
i met some cool people and made some
really good friends
and i met all of you guys
damn dude it's been a journey hasn't it
are you ready to go
yeah uh one sec
[Music]
oh
oh no he brought the [ __ ] thing
that was from the shed y'all
[Music]
i'm gonna do what i've always done just
a new place
it bro hell no so he went to youtube wow
and it was so powerful too because like
it was like
he changed the [ __ ] world bro by
playing among us and that i feel that
you know
so
i think the reason i'm watching these
videos
is not to
say anything negative about those two
beautiful souls and i really do think
they're nice and i'm not
not trying to say anything but
they were a little bit dramatic i think
we can all agree i think you could a
little melodramatic
i mean you play among us dude chill out
it's not that [ __ ] serious
i'm just saying i'm just saying
so with all that being said
well
i'm this is scary
i'm scared to do this guys but i have a
huge announcement and uh well
you have a queued up dan yeah all right
let's just roll it guys
ever since i was young i knew
i had to be a podcaster but i never
could have guessed where that journey
would take me
from humble beginnings across the globe
to exciting new paths into unexplored
territories
i laughed i cried
i [ __ ] myself
i got canceled
i made friends that will last a lifetime
lost those friends got canceled again
got a face rash from putting too much
cortisone cream on my face oh [ __ ]
for external anal and genital itching
diarrhea again this time it looks like
pesto
this
is my weapon
my excalibur
when i pulled this from the stone so
many years ago i knew i was destined for
greatness
some say the sword is mightier than the
pen but you know what does more damage
than all of them a microphone with a
master orator behind it me
i'm thinking like
iconic icono iconicary is that a word no
no there's been ups
downs
but through it all there was you
the audience
who hates me on most days but it seems
like some of you actually like me
and now we've reached the next chapter
of this strange beautiful journey
together as we're about to hit 3 million
subscribers i'm gonna do what i've
always done in the same exact place as
i've always done it not doing it any
different same place same platform
same exact everything what i've always
done i'll do it again more doing it the
same way that i've done it except the
only difference is there's not a
difference actually it's completely the
same place
ethan
just one question
are you ready to go
no i need another minute
actually you know what i gotta take a
dump can you set the time back by like
20 minutes
all right
[Music]
well there you have it you know i didn't
want to get one up by these these
dramatic kids because i've been up we've
been on youtube all right where's our
[ __ ] dramatic music where's youtube
reaching out to us and paying us and
making awesome [ __ ] dramatic trailer
i want to know where's my [ __ ]
respect
you know
yeah
sorry i'm still recovering a little bit
so you know yes we're here and we're
we're not we're not going anywhere okay
it's all about the respect
thank you
yo you know how much they probably spent
on those trailers for like psychonaut
[ __ ] we that [ __ ] was free we shot that
[ __ ] in like 30 minutes
you know what i'm saying yeah literally
i bet you youtube spit dropped like 100k
to produce that [ __ ] sure it theirs
looked
a little bit not much not much better by
much but it yeah you know
well you know we made it and that's
respect
just saying
there you go guys no teens you all been
goofed you've been trolled you've been
had
you guys gone you got silly job [ __ ]
silly song you got zonked my dudes
that was fun though
i love that cutaway where i was like the
pen the mic is mightier than the pen and
then
i couldn't speak
couldn't
speak well
[Applause]
oh yeah yeah
you know what's interesting though dr
disrespect but on youtube for a long
time and he [ __ ] hates youtube gaming
look at this
he tweeted this like the same
day
kuno
uh
joined
and what is dr d he probably pulls
pretty good numbers when he streams
right probably even better than
well cyclones debut stream when we
popped in on it had like 32k
live viewers which is about what we're
sitting at right now
um when no we've got um we've got um the
almost 33. oh my god can you round up a
little bit you're right that is 32.9
thank you uh repeating of course
but um
but yeah uh when doctor disrespect
debuted on
youtube it was like 200k or something it
was like no respect for the man yeah
they won't engage with them at all which
i think they're just scared of whatever
happened with twitch if i had to assume
or they're just like cool you're on here
for free fu
right but he says i had to unfollow
youtube gaming they don't even support
us why support them it sounds like you
can't even get some get a hold of
someone
yeah well i mean that's a common thing
at youtube right being difficult to get
a hold of anybody unless you have susan
on speed dial like you so i have no
problem getting a hold of someone no
that's not true i actually lately i i
have i'm it's not been a good time yeah
i wonder if we can get doc to call in
because i'm kind of curious about his
let me dm him right now
man he might be down to talk about it
um i'm curious about his experience
because if we gonna all be joining
youtube
which i think is great i love streaming
on youtube i welcome all i mean it's
great for us right bring them all over
let's get that whole pool swimming in uh
i'd argue it's good for both twitch
streamers and youtube streamers get that
competition it's a fire under twitch
yeah yeah totally
yeah
all right i'm just messaging uh doc yeah
on the youtube side too because you know
youtube just implemented uh some
features that have been on twitch
forever like um
there is like a
i forget what they call it but the
equivalent of their raids they've added
to their live streaming recently and a
few other things so yeah i mean you know
it's good that these platforms feel like
they need to compete for talent bro
doctor disrespects first stream at 400
thousand live viewers and you can't even
get something to talk to 400k yeah
damn that's nuts that's like what the
world cup gets and [ __ ]
that's what we get on a slow day though
yeah
definitely as the number one podcast in
the world anyway that's it
just fun times
but there actually is some really
interesting stories today i want to talk
about
um you know we should do our ad reads
though we're at 35 minutes already all
right after i do these ad reads there's
two of them on a blast through i want to
talk about dave chappelle getting
attacked
at the hollywood ball it was
specifically interesting because we went
to see our friend christina p
there's this comedy festival going on
called uh
netflix is a joke right and christina p
was performing and we saw her and then
went back to her hotel to for drinks and
apparently dave chappelle had his after
party at that hotel so like we were in
an empty bar and then just like a rush
of people came in
uh to party and everyone was buzzing
about how dave chappelle got attacked it
was kind of nuts yeah and shout out will
smith you for making everything possible
for me for being a trailblazer in that
topic
which i hate to say i was right again
but come on guys
when are you guys going
when are you guys going to stop quite
stop questioning me and just accept that
everything i say is prophetic
thank you love for laughing
no i'm laughing because it's true
obviously no absolutely okay let's thank
our sponsors real fast
our wonderful sponsors such as harry
oh okay
okay
i love me some harry's razor
it's all about that daily routine you
know what i mean you got the razors i
whenever i shave that i don't do a lot
of shaving obviously but what i do shave
is the back of my neck i'd like to keep
that clean and also under my balls hi
alfredo
nowhere else just under my balls what
timing he's sitting right here man for
his sake you know alfredo likes when my
under my balls is clean
anyway anyway
uh
you get a starter set
it's got a juicy meaty handle the razors
are good and clean and powerful you get
this foaming shave gel that's smooth and
beautiful and exfoliating and
lubricating
pretty incredible stuff actually harry's
is giving their best offer to our
listeners first time harry's customers
can redeem a starter set for just three
bucks
right on one two three harrys.com
h3
this includes a five blade cartridge a
weighted handle a foaming shave gel
and a travel cover to protect your
blades on the go it's a 13 value but
you're getting just for three bucks
you know
you get everything you need for a great
shave and nothing but that harry's
blades hold up better than ever guys who
have tried it
say their eighth shave is it's just as
sharp
as their first
ela loves this stuff too she uses it all
the time so it works for
the ladies just as well
uh they actually have the highest
customer satisfaction in the shaving
industry and they're still offering a no
risk trial
don't like your shave well don't worry
it's on them that's a refund
guys no questions asked
now look same incredible offer there's
really never been a better time to try
harry's
so just go to harry's dot com slash h3
today and get your starter set for just
three bucks that's harry's dot com slash
h3 okay
thank you
and to our
stalwart
supporter
stamps.com
we love stamps
if you got a small business inflation
isn't doing you any favors right now
it's harder than ever just stay
profitable but if you're looking for a
way to cut costs mailing and shipping is
a great place to start
simply use stamps.com to mail and ship
and get access to exclusive discounts
and great rates on shipping from usps
and ups
it's an easy way to keep more money in
your pocket
yep
stance.com saves you time money and
stress for more than 20 year stamps.com
has been indispensable for over 1
million businesses
they give you access to all the post
office and ups shipping services that
you need for from your computer and
here's the best part you got fat
discounts you can't get anywhere else
like 30 off usps rates and 86 off ups
that's basically free
dan um your girlfriend ali uses stamps
right yes she does she's got a small
business that she runs uh selling her
art prints
right she ships it all using stamps.com
and integrates with her
her own personal website and um what do
you call it like that's she's on etsy
and yeah that kind of stuff you want to
give her a shout out yeah it's uh skirts
art skirts
skirts and you should gonna use stamps
to fulfill your freaking order that's
right stamps.com because she gets like a
scale mm-hmm at home sits right you
weigh it at the scale at home and then
it automatically prints the correct
postage charges you probably because you
have a card on file yep and then you you
put it in the mail or or they'll come
pick it up from your door
you don't have to think about it
seriously
i mean it's unbelievable
whoa
zach stuttering the other day
oh that wasn't even edited play that
again
that was not edited
what you thunk a cat got your thunders
there
anyway guys it's honestly if you're
mailing anything stamps.com is the place
to do it it's fantastic it's for any
letter any package anywhere start
mailing and shipping with stamps.com and
keep more money in your pocket every day
sign up with the promo code h3 for a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale no long-term commitment or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter the code h3 thank you thank
you thank you
[Music]
okay
so uh yeah so we were having drink by
the way i got
i think i'm hungover i was like why do i
feel weird i had three glasses of wine
and i'm like
i don't drink ever too much wine it hits
hard man too much wine sorry too much
wine and you know what's crazy ryan
kevin if you're watching i had three
glasses of wine so i might say too much
and i didn't even joke about having sex
with a kid right which he did yes he did
what what did he say about her again
uh an appropriate relationship with a
four-year-old natalie portman yeah like
i never said that you know that's wild
drive angry
and drive angry
so
have you guys seen this and heard about
this everyone came into the
bar just totally shocked
um apparently someone charged chappelle
on stage
and he had a knife and a gun on him is
that so there was there was uh
mixed reports it ended up being that the
gun was a replica gun so it wasn't a
real gun but it had a knife in it that's
the way it's being framed in the news
he had a fake gun with a knife in it yes
or like attached to it or something he
he had a knife he there was no firearm
but they thought it was a firearm
because he had a replica gun that's like
a very strange that's like a hi a
professional
fake
a replica
when they use the term replica it sounds
like that yeah but i mean it could have
just been some mall ninja [ __ ] like yeah
apparent apparently it's just just to
even be weirder chris rock came on stage
and made a will smith joke
chris rock was there
he's like yo was that chris was that
will smith right yeah [ __ ] my wife's
not i'm going to okay
but the crazy thing is that this took
place at the hollywood bowl which is one
of the premium
venues in los angeles sure and the
security there's got to be tight tight
tight and the stage is like fairly
removed from the audience i don't know
how the hell that guy got up there and
attacked him you know yeah but uh it
happened here's the video of it
check it out
oh this is the whole damn video tmz got
that exclusive good [ __ ] boy yeah there
was a lot of really shaky cell phone
footage but this is tmz tmz had the best
one but i gotta tip the hat to tmz those
guys know how to get that exclusive [ __ ]
i do and they never claim us yeah big
shout out to tmz you know they used to
claim us a lot back in the day and no
company in the history of my career has
ever done this they reached out to us
and said hey we notice you guys are
using a lot of our clips we want to
white list you so that we'll never
accidentally claim you and and to this
day i say thank you tmz you guys are the
[ __ ] legends for that man the only
company that's ever done that and by the
way their whole business model is like
getting that exclusive [ __ ] so if
anybody would have like a legitimate
claim to like hey we're protecting our
ip it's them and they're the one not
that it would be right by the way but
but they're the ones that give us the
pass i mean it's incredible it is pretty
wild
well that being said let's enjoy
the dj table is one of the most prolific
producers that hip hop has ever
presented the mighty man live
ladies and gentlemen
make some noise for hip-hop history
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he said the uh hard er there i noticed
which i guess
is
funny
yeah i don't know how that guy got up
there he got that front row seats
that must have been an expensive seat
just for the opportunity thank you lena
i mean he could have just rushed down
i mean you know the bowl right you
you've been in this show there's like
there's guards at all the yeah usually
but i mean maybe he just saw an
opportunity where they weren't paying
attention for a second and hopped over
and it's kind of crazy how they got to
start beefing up security for [ __ ]
comedians
this is great i've never seen the whole
clip like this it was usually just a
really shoddy guy tackling him
apparently the guy got his ass beat
backstage it was like a
yeah there's a bit of him going in the
ambulance and his arm he's straight up
like yeah his arm is pretzeled out
backwards
i think dave went backstage to stomp him
[Applause]
thank god
that was clumsy
that's true
he was clumsy
the stage seems slippery because
security falls as well i noticed that
i guess dave's sweat maybe saved his
life if he was coming at him with the
knife you know yeah like clearly his
goal wasn't just to get up there and
tackle him
that's not that
it's not worth getting
your arm back well he he got charged
with it with assault with a deadly
weapon didn't he
i heard uh yes he's being charged with
the assault with a deadly weapon so
there you go
that's scary
[Applause]
thank you son
it was a
it was a trans man
people were offended by that
yeah keeping it classy of course
it's like why'd you get first of all it
wasn't and it's like dude come on get it
wasn't even
it wasn't though so why'd you had to do
that you already got beef with them
never miss an opportunity to uh
insult trans people i guess
is his uh but okay it's a joke
i believe in his previous statement he
said if someone was to kill him to be a
trans person but obviously still not
defining well that's well obviously
that's the people he has like a lot of
yeah beef with so
but do we know anything about the motive
of the attacker not yet yet there's not
really any i mean my assumption would be
so there's some info in the dock he um
in 2020 he
he's a you know
rapper uh soundcloud rapper and he
released the song called dave chappelle
and in this one of the songs he said
that uh he was something about the
hollywood bowl i have this specific
lyric in the dark wait really yeah huh
he's been planning this yeah and
apparently uh chappelle was supposed to
have a show like um
when cove had first hit
um
which is when he released the song so
maybe there was some type of correlation
there just speculating but um yeah
there's
in one of his songs he says
something about the bowl it says in 2020
he released a song called dave chappelle
where he mumbles some lyrics walking
straight into the bow
so it probably had nothing to do with
the with the trans stuff just some
lunatic because there's no indication
whatsoever it has anything to do that's
wild bro come on they weren't even the
ones to attack you dude
some nutty ass rapper
why is this guy got to give a bad name
to soundcloud rappers
who have such a sterling reputation you
know they've been through enough
get out
wait why is it playing slow-mo it's a
connection oh it's just a replay yeah
[Music]
it wasn't
it was a trans man
actually it's not even funny i think
that's the biggest problem with the
comment
that's the yeah yeah
yeah dave chappelle is disappointing but
i don't think he should be stabbed on
stage no so of course not yeah this
whole trance thing is weird it sucks
because i like him a lot i mean he's
great
funny everything he makes
i just don't know why he can't give up
the whole war with trans people thing
like his last special
was
almost entirely about his whole issue
with the trans people and the jokes and
how he won't be science and it's like
more than anything i just i'm over it
bro just to get bring some new material
man it does
yeah he's milked it for a long time i
think i saw i this wasn't broadcast live
or anything so you weren't able to watch
the special but i saw
some people saying that he
made some jokes about it in this
performance as well
not surprised
well he had explicitly said in his last
special that he was done with the topic
oh
but he can't get enough he can't he
can't stop himself the thing is when you
making like trans jokes and all this
reactionary stuff
he gets a lot of new fans of people
conservatives and people that don't like
trans people who are like this guy is
telling it like nobody you know you get
the worst kind of people to start
being a fan
yep
yeah it's disappointing
but uh it wasn't
it was a trans man
which yeah i mean later chris rock came
in and said the much more appropriate
much funnier joke it was will smith yeah
like
it was right there
it was right there dave
but i have a question do you think this
would have happened if not for will
smith's thing would this guy feel like
he could have gotten away with that
because when have you ever seen this
and then right out the skirting right on
the back of the
the will smith slap yeah i mean it does
seem
the timing does make you
think of that i mean who's to say
let's do a poll i want to do a poll
because my opinion of that whole thing
was like great now will smith smacking
comedians
uh you're gonna it's gonna be empowering
people to do it more right so let's see
what do you guys think you think this
would would have happened if not for
will smith trailblazing attacking a
comedian
without would this have happened without
the will smith will smith trailblazing
uh
yes people jump on stage all the time do
they and attack and try to [ __ ]
attack the comedian i don't know
i don't think so
i mean i mean has dave chappelle's been
doing this a long time has he ever been
attacked on stage like this
i don't think i remember
i feel like it would uh
definitely
have been brought up if so
but
i mean people jump rush stages i i would
say the context you see it most is at
concerts and not generally to attack a
performer but to just be a jackass and
you know jump around and then they end
up getting tackled by security i know
people rush the stage but like this is
with the intent to harm the person
right this has happened without the will
smith slap most people say yes
although it's close
i think not personally
you know
some people are saying it was staged
come on now
you see you you once you go oh you see
that guy's arm yeah go look at the video
of the guy getting into the ambulance
and you'll you'll change yeah you see
his arm there's nothing staged about
that [ __ ]
okay well
oh i have confusing pull dan
it's not confusing they just
they can't
they say it literally every time no
matter what so
bad pole bad pull i'm seeing bad pull
dan did this have happened without the
terrible
slap incident okay yes or no
i don't see what's confusing it's not
there's nothing confusing oh wait people
are saying bad pull though damn
you know what i've got a different poll
that i'm going to put up oh no i
was i do think we should add like see
results so people who don't really care
uh should just can we do that a third
well you could have like just an option
see result if it's
where we don't need uh you need to vote
here let's see how this this poll does
was the last poll clear
this is unclear
wait it says guessing yes that's right
this is [ __ ] rigged that's right it
is rigged rig pull
that's a bad pull
that's a variable the audience says
otherwise we have a hundred percent
saying that it was a it was a clear poll
thank you dan
100
all right let's move on um i'm going to
send
an invite to our little guest
uh oliver's calling in uh-huh all right
so maybe
i'm sending the invite now
and maybe you can
set up what we'll be discussing
yeah but anyway the guys got arrested he
went to jail 30 000 bail
and uh yadda yadda
all right so oliver's calling in
now you guys may have heard that oliver
is accusing this guy kid uh
leory leroy leroy
he doesn't deserve the dignity of me
saying his name right
kid leroy
uh and his music uh direct music video
director specifically christian
uh
of stealing ideas now you guys be the
judge i'm going to show this clip
now to in my opinion this is pretty
resounding like straight rip off and
oliver's been trying to make some noise
about this and
as much as i hate the guy
i do have to kind of
um
kid leroy's new music video copies
multiple shots from my videos as an
underground indie artist who writes and
directs their own music videos i am so
sick of big artists ripping me off now i
know it's not kid leroy's fault so i
looked into the director and it turns
out this dude followed me on instagram
coincidence i think not kid leroy's new
music video conference
multiple shots okay
now a lot of people thought this was
like a troll or something this is real
this is actually serious yeah when i
first saw it
i mean
he's just
he's always trolling so often that i
just my default assumption i see
anything from all of her is that it's
some sort of joke but that's the problem
i don't think a lot of people
not a joke this time
so let's look at the shot by shot here
so being dragged here i'm going to mute
it because i don't want to hear oliver
the piano thing is pretty specific man
that shot
yeah
it's a little saucy don't you all think
it's very sassy
extremely so there was a rolling stones
article about the controversy yes indeed
the exact same thing oliver tree accuses
kid loroy
director of copying his videos
you gotta try to be more creative about
the way you steal tree tells rolling
stones
oliver i'm not reading this whole
article
[Laughter]
i'm just waiting for him to call in
where is he
uh i sent him the link and they said uh
he will be ready
um this guy loves wasting my time like
bro i'm trying to help you out and your
[ __ ] la dragging your feet
i'm texting him right now
let's see messages from close friends
and industry folks alike flooded oliver
tree's phone after kid leroy released a
cinematic eccentric video for a thousand
miles
yadda yadda yadda he stole the [ __ ]
thing
neither leroy nor the uh director
responded
to rolling stones multiple requests for
a comment although on an instagram post
about the visual
bisshuler who's uh
[ __ ] his name what breast shealer
breast juice let's feel the breasts
jiller
breslauer
bres lauer who directed videos such as
liz on little knows x's industry baby
and dojo cat streets okay so he's he's a
big time director
and he said he was inspired by the
concept of spy versus spy comics in
making of thousand miles
[ __ ] bro
but tree doesn't bite it's all about
taking something that exists and
flipping it and doing it something new
but you got to be smart about it tree
says you got to try to be more creative
about the way you steal after tree
shared his tick tock
commenters flooded leroy's instagram
accusing him of ripping off tree this is
copy paste wrote one fan
after consulting with lawyers
tree ultimately decided not to pursue
legal action against a breast dealer
or leroy and he said he's not trying to
ruin the guy's career either he just
wants to raise awareness for smaller
artists whose visual and sonic
conceptions what what the [ __ ] is a
sonic conception
are sometimes used for inspiration
and prominent acts often without credit
all right well oliver if you want me to
talk about this you may get on the line
right now because i'm not i'm going to
spend my whole show waiting for you
okay
they said they'll jump on in just a sec
so old man what are they doing well i
i may have timed this kind of poorly
because i had told them 2 30 and i
thought it would take a little bit but
he can't it's four minutes early he
can't get on the phone
i told him we're ready now and he said
okay we'll hop on
do you want me to read more of this
dumbass article what the [ __ ] it just
quotes oliver it's boring
[Laughter]
uh let's see let's just go in conclusion
i'm a much smaller artist is that true
is this leroy guy i looked into it yeah
uh he has
uh he's managed by the good or brawn
he's a giant dude like he's really never
heard of him yeah he's huge what's his
big song you never heard of him i
thought you're a giant fan you
definitely heard of him well i mean i
heard of him once i i only heard him
through this and i watch
the be the video what it's like
he's done songs with justin bieber
uh juice world sing one for us zack
someone says this is how we feel when we
wait for you ethan i'm sorry now i know
now i know how it feels
got him
people say he's an industry plant
don't they say that about everyone
they do kind of say that about everybody
what do you think uh ian thoughts
industry plan thoughts
i mean um ian he he has a lot of support
bieber seems he's like bieber's guy
so i don't know
[Music]
his protege i'd say is he protege of
bieber
of justin
bieber
i wasn't trying you've gotten big body
beams i forgot when he lost his ass over
skee-ball
he almost decked his wife because she
beat him at skee-ball play that again
maybe i wasn't trying
yo
celebrity ain't easy man
one day you're on top of the world and
next you're decking your wife because
you lost his skee ball just saying
it's tough my wife went out for yogurt
stop me and then i had a hard time
all right well you know what oliver i'm
[ __ ] done with you dude uh what else
is in here i'm trying to drag this out
blah blah blah he says he's not trying
to yeah i already read that there was an
interesting update on okay you know here
this is interesting and i this might
understand why oliver's so pissed at
this guy
kid leroy look at this
this is oliver's thing right
nominated by the way h3 choice awards
nominated
but i'll tell you who did win
kid leroy
and justin bieber favorite music collab
winner
oh uh
it looks like he just hopped on so give
me just a second to queue it up god i'm
so i'm already annoyed with him all
right well you can let him know hold on
one second
okay
i see him
and uh
hello oliver are you there
dude why are you making me wait bro like
i'm trying to i'm trying to promote your
[ __ ] and i'm sitting here what no
you listen to me
i have been waiting for the last 25
[ __ ] minutes dude what is taking down
you know what's the problem your your
drapes don't match your [ __ ] uh what
is it carpet the carpet don't match the
drapes my dog look at that blonde hair
it's nothing close to that beard color
do you literally invite me on to insult
me right now
why did you think i invited you on
oliver
like seriously do you not know the drill
by now
i honestly don't know yeah me neither
all right so what's going on you got
ripped off by this dude
it was bad dude who's this kid leroy
honestly
i hadn't heard of him until this whole
incident and the whole thing
just caught me by surprise i was really
taken back you know i'm not trying to
blame
kid leroy um
i don't know if he had any involvement
with that but
you know at the end of the day
you know these artists are not directing
their videos they hire another person
and they do it and they just present
them
uh an idea and like you do like you do
no i write and direct all my videos i
take a lot of pride in that and that's
something why
i kind of made you know a statement
about this is that i've been frustrated
because
i've dedicated many years of my life to
making these videos um
i took
a deal with atlantic records and was
able to
subsidize making these videos but they
really didn't pay me any money i took no
money so that i could make videos and um
you know at the end of the day
i got you know
the short end of the stick we got these
bigger people who come in and they just
recreate the same [ __ ] you already made
and
i don't know a part of it that's a
little frustrating is just seeing on his
instagram he's like you know i had one
week to make this video and it's like
did he really say that he said and it's
like well what do you do when you have a
week to make a music video well you just
steal other people's [ __ ] let's just
take oliver trees video let's take a
couple of them shot here shot there shot
here
so i don't know that was just kind of
like how many views did his music video
get that's the jacked you i don't know
but we shouldn't even mention the name
of it i'm not trying to promote his song
what's the name of it dan
please don't say it i'm just going to go
to youtube i just want to check the
views
what's the name of the single i don't
know but don't show his screen
somebody what was the name of the single
please don't
i i don't know because oliver didn't say
it in his video because he's you know
not trying to give this guy okay i'll
find out fine i know his name is kid
leroy kid
please don't don't even type his name in
kid leroy check him out now i got to be
honest with you oliver
as much of a fan i am in yours and all
that
i actually liked his music video better
than any of the ones i saw here
right now and i'm not saying that to be
rude like i genuinely thought that this
whoever directed this it just did like a
way better job isn't that crazy it's
called a thousand miles oh don't even
say the name
don't say it i'll dislike it is that
good that would be great okay dislike
so um ethan ethan yeah
you're joking right when you said that
you liked his video it doesn't have that
many views though it only has 8.8
million i thought like
don't show it i don't even want to
support it you're doing too much here so
the thing about his video was that like
artistically shot for shot i was i just
felt like i just felt it more and so i
was like well does it matter if someone
rips you off if they do it better than
you you know what i mean
how [ __ ] dare you dude first of all
it's so much easier to recreate
something and make a better version of
it second of all you're talking about a
guy who had one song with the biggest
artist in the world justin bieber so he
had one of the biggest songs of the year
of course he's got bigger budgets i'm
over here scraping by begging atlantic
records to try to get one of these
budgets to work
it's way easier to do when you have
already a pre-existing blueprint and
you're just going to recreate it so i'm
not going to say too much about it but
hey what are you looking at okay so
basically
i i sense you have a chip on your
shoulder about this kid leroy guy
if we go to your wikipedia page you'll
notice that there's a kid's choice award
nominated an h3 choice award also
nominated you didn't win that one
but
why are you doing this this is not what
we agreed to do you invited me on for a
cordial conversation i'm trying to
remain calm here but you're [ __ ]
pissing me off dude
okay well i just thought it was i'm just
i thought it was interesting context but
what you see is kid leroy won
actually her favorite music
collaboration the kids choice award does
that have anything to do with you
calling them out
i have no idea i think honestly
staying
the situation has brought more attention
to kid leroy than you know
really i'm putting the guy on i'm
promoting his [ __ ] video with this
[ __ ] i'm thinking about potentially
taking the post down
which post oh you think so
i think so man i mean that might be part
of the reason why he won the kids choice
award
i'm sure yeah i may have i may have
accidentally um
you know what's crazy i think when we
did we told people to go vote for oliver
i may have posted something saying kid
leroy
that's a big chord it's not even i was
like vote for kid leroy actually
i don't remember that's an incredible so
what are you gonna do about it i mean
this guy ripped you off for sure there's
no debating it right like it's shot for
shot like come on y'all [ __ ] ripped
oh so you admit it yeah no i admit it
it's just better no i admit it totally
ripped you off this is it you can't
debate
about whose is better okay this has
nothing to do with quality this has to
do with
trying to at least put a creative spin
on something and the whole point of
creating art is you're never going to
create something truly original it's
just impossible who do you remember a
new song you know wait let me just
finish your ethan you're okay
okay all right sorry so you're never
going to reinvent the wheel with this
but
there's a lot more creative ways to
steal and the whole idea is you got to
put your spin on it but
it was just fishy man the that the exact
angles the different perspectives i mean
even if you look at the shot that's
overhead and seeing the way that his
hand's positioned yeah that's my
signature move i've done that in like
five or six times i'm playing it you
know i'm playing it right now the piano
dropping i mean whoever dropped the
piano is like
you know i've never seen a piano drop
ever that was my idea yeah you're the
first person ever to drop the piano
thank you
yeah
you have you heard of wylie coyote
people been dropping pianos for a
[ __ ] hundred years bro
yeah wiley coyote dude
[ __ ] road runner dude
i i honestly am i'm trying to keep it
together here because the truth is
i love wiley kylie no yeah he's though
he's dumb he's he's awesome yeah
roadrunner he [ __ ] dodged that [ __ ]
he's too fast
i know that's what's so funny about it
huh but you know what
road runner
truth is wiley coyote and roadrunner
like if you look at the way that it's
shot
it's very different
that's true
that's true i'll give you that
so so but if we look like this this shot
here this this is the one where his
hands are all sprawled out it's like bro
are you trying to be oliver tree are you
trying to be kid leroy you know
yeah and the thing is also who would
want to be oliver tree you should be
proud not to be all over today we
already know that didn't work
you know yeah yeah the oliver tree thing
is not working
it didn't work for me and it's certainly
not gonna work for him and what i will
say is
um you know i think that's a big reason
why the video that he posted is just
doing so poorly is they should have
ripped off a bigger artist a better
better artist better artist as well yes
perhaps
because like if you're gonna steal at
least steal from someone good
i'm not going to go i'm not going to
copy the homework of like the biggest
idiot in the class i'm going to copy the
smart kid
basically he copied like the dumb the
biggest moral
i wouldn't yeah if you're referring to
yourself no you didn't copy me
had to say this ethan you know the more
you say this the more you point it out i
want to say it sounds like you're
talking about yourself oh nice wow
that's super slick insult bro except you
didn't copy my music video
well i'm just saying it sounds like
you're projecting
some of your own insider the only thing
i'm projecting is these nuts on your mom
all right all right don't bring my
mother into this
so we got this shot this overnight shot
we got that that one's a rip like i'm
sorry bro well that's the thing the
videos end the exact same [ __ ] way
bro yeah that one's a rip they even have
the exact same ambulance and i'm trying
to figure out because i know there's
only one rental house that rents that
exact ambulance they had to go and see
you think so wow i know so is it the
same one
it's just not nighttime so it looks
different
let's see
christian
and he follows you that's damning so did
you ever follow him back a message and
be like yo what's up player
bro i don't even follow you i don't
follow anyone and i don't use social
media so the truth is no i didn't want
to hit him up
no
i'm not going to say anything i'm not
trying to send people to send hate to
him that's not the point here it's more
just
you know the truth is
it hurts when
i've dedicated my lifetime to making
this aesthetic this style and
someone can just lift it as their own
get the bag
for a bigger artist that's kind of the
main core of it and you know the truth
is
no one really saw my videos my videos
never really did
numbers and so it's a little bit like
it's a shame that my life's work is just
going unnoticed and other people can
kind of lift it and bring it to the main
so we're saying so here i'll do
something so guys go watch oliver tree's
videos you know the real ones okay and
then you can at least say
ethan's right this one's not as good but
at least watch it and give him a shot
like that's what we're trying to do
right
we want people to go watch your videos
yes yeah but you know i want people to
watch them and say wow
what a creative genius
maybe one of the most
original [ __ ]
you can't even say you can't even keep a
straight face you can't even [ __ ] say
it with a straight face because you know
how ridiculous it sounds
i'll just say it
go ahead
i stole all my [ __ ] from miley coyote
yeah i [ __ ] knew it i knew it but
that's what you mean right you say be
more creative
when you steal [ __ ] and amen brother
nobody [ __ ] trace that back to the to
the looney tunes from the 50s
um
i think you should message him
no i don't think so he's a big shot he's
a big shot it's [ __ ] up he can steal
your work like that
you know
yeah i don't know i'm not it's no hate
you know i'm not trying to go after
people i was just hopefully
thought it would maybe bring some
awareness to my videos that i had
created in the past and the truth is it
did not um nobody watched mine they
didn't they didn't go up at all and
people know more people didn't get to
watch here let me go to you
i noticed that it just boosted his video
so i think it was kind of a
failed attempt if i will
well let's see let's go have a look here
uh oliver tree music videos bro why are
you posting so much [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
bro you posted your whole album on
youtube why would you do that i didn't
want it the label made me do it why do
they do that
so people can listen to it man actually
there's people out there who try to
listen to my music and i know you never
listen to the album but there are people
out there and there might even be one
person watching this show right now that
actually listens to the album and so
people can go listen to the whole cowboy
tiers for free on youtube
yes it's free everywhere bro that's what
streaming is it's all free
that's not true apple music i mean oh
you can listen for free if you don't
have premium you just get ads
i don't know i don't have any of them
i'm not sure well i think most of your
fans probably don't have money so that's
probably good they're probably too young
to be able to buy [ __ ] that's true i
mean the sweet spot in my my demo is
pretty much ages one to four so yeah
most those kids they're relying on their
parents piggy banks
well your music videos your premium ones
what do you mean premium they're all
premium no well some of them don't have
a lot of views so i count those out
they [ __ ] fell the [ __ ] off bro
uh well this one got 200 million so
that's a big ops that's an anomaly
that's a tick-tock anomaly the rest of
them did nothing like that man it's been
one
big l after another this one got 20
million that's not bad that's bad
what that's good maybe for you dude
well for you too look at your [ __ ]
[ __ ] for you too
bro i have a lot more followers on
youtube than you okay and i noticed
you've been going down a lot of
followers well that's true you're losing
them by the day well my my old main
channel that i haven't posted to in like
10 years has like double your sub so
eating no but i was talking to you about
that that thing is rendered obsolete and
back at that time it was way easier to
get followers and i just no it wasn't
stop the nonsense oliver that's a fact
it was harder back then now now you get
subs like nothing it's like oh subs a
little subs
because i don't care bro it's because i
don't play the game
you don't play the game all you do is
lose followers every day that's your
thing
talk to the hand
well i will say this
can you please take off the kid the
right [ __ ] you're pissing me off now
dude
this is your channel what are you
talking about take this off the [ __ ]
screen ethan it's not cool man i was
trying to be fun i was trying to laugh
with you a little bit but this is
crossing the [ __ ] line dude
take that [ __ ] off oh it's the green
screen i didn't realize okay that's not
[ __ ] cool okay i didn't realize that
right now yeah i didn't see
well listen but listen this is i'm just
i have to tell you i'm a huge [ __ ]
fan of this guy he's got this amazing
voice he's got this association with
justin bieber who's like honestly biebs
is i mean i'm a belieber i've been a
belieber i will be a believer no bro are
you [ __ ] drunk i am hungover to be
honest but the truth is that i'm [ __ ]
riding kid leroy
forever okay [ __ ] oliver tree kid leroy
forever steal all his music what are you
saying
you send me some [ __ ] do you want me to
open this package
i gave you something as a gift but no i
don't want you to open it i want the
gift back have your [ __ ] team send
that [ __ ] back bring it on camera no
don't bring it on camera i want that
[ __ ] back oliver sent me something
bro
the agreement was
you would have me on the show
would help promote my music videos i did
that
no you didn't all you did was clown me
in front of your measly audience that's
losing people by the [ __ ] day
listen bro i'm not gonna pretend like i
don't love kid leroy uh you're okay you
know your music's fine you're like
marinating you have a long ways to go
but kid leroy he's there he's ready to
pounce anyway go ahead dan's opening
this package all right no don't open it
yet i need to make a official
announcement i want ethan to open it
because it's a big deal that i can have
him bring it out on camera not dan he
just does nothing all day all right
we'll make the announcement
all right can you put the thing in the
screen because part of it's cut off it's
a giant box what do you want me to do
it's a giant
it's like way to move the box over
dan can you move the box over dan keep
moving it he he's just opening it
don't open it i want ethan to [ __ ] i
will i will
he's just he's taking the time the tape
off man god
there's tape on it move the box over
more yeah yeah
all right can you see
uh ethan can you sit down yeah
uh
does your chair go any lower yeah hold
on
how's that
[Laughter]
all right
do you have one of those like submarine
tubes that we can maybe have you look up
from um do you guys have any uh kind of
submarine tube or glass i could hold up
and look over the top with
periscope no we don't have a periscope
okay well i like the sound effects thank
you zach
uh don't think zach zack stop
zach i appreciate that zach no more no
more submarine sound zach was that
submarine sounds or was that bong water
because i know this dude's a fat stoner
that's zach's don't look stop all right
what do you want me to do zach play that
[ __ ]
i need my drum roll play my bong water
all right all right
hey i'm going to make the announcement
okay hold your hook go ahead all right
so
it's a big deal
i spent the last year
working with a scooter company nagi
and we've been making
the world's first
oliver tree custom scooter
and this is a big [ __ ] deal because
this is something that i've personally
designed myself i've spent so much
[ __ ] time trying to get this right
and i've made 32 different models you
sure kid leroy didn't make it shut the
[ __ ] up ethan let me talk
okay can we get a drum roll and just let
the guy i'm done talking so should i
open it
let's show the camera let's see the
[ __ ] response i want you to know and
then i want to see you riding around can
you pull the cardboard off you gotta
ride this [ __ ] after
okay
and this is a beta version this isn't
the official packaging okay this is not
the official packaging i got you a
[ __ ] promo one of one piece this is
literally the first open please these
things are not on the market
this is a uh looks like an electric
dual motor scooter
let me get ethan open it what are you
doing damn it's got tape
what you can't open tape you can't be
trusted with a knife
what is it what is it what is it no you
can't [ __ ] br
you can't this [ __ ] belongs to you you
can't convert it back to me you [ __ ]
destroyed it
oliver this is [ __ ]
look at this you brought the [ __ ] up
god damn it i'm spilling i got kids bro
i got kids i can't be having this cursed
bram on my [ __ ]
oh my god dude i got you so good what a
sucker
oh man i got you so good bro
you walked in
you walked into that one you stupid
[ __ ] dude yo this curse is yours
alone [ __ ] [ __ ] you no it's not dude
because good luck
you broke that [ __ ] no no no no
and ethan i learned the hard way i will
never accept another
different from you
ever dude i'm done shout out kid leroy
shout out kid leroy
the best musician in the game everybody
go watch kilroy cut them off cut him off
[Music]
yeah cut him no i don't talk to him
anymore ethan no no he's done he's done
oliver thanks for stopping in no no not
thanks
nothing guess what kid leroy number one
best collaboration kids choice best
collaboration 2022 with justin bieber
cut it off i don't want to see him
anymore how many times i got to ask [ __ ]
you know
yeah when i say cut him off i may cut
him off why you gotta it takes me a
second
i don't know why i bring that guy on you
try to do a nice thing for him
this kit first of all kid leroy has the
voice of a god okay so for him to even
try to hold a candle to him
is ridiculous and second of all why do i
even try to do a nice thing for him i
bring him on then you know i got this
can you get a shot of this can somebody
get a shot he tilted down yeah i got it
we saw it you know
yeah
you touched it last by the way
i never touched it until now yep
uh oh
[Music]
oh spilled the water i'm lucky i didn't
crush the dogs damn lucky that they
weren't standing there yeah they weren't
good you okay alfredo
don't touch the curse [ __ ] discouraged
uh
the curse
[ __ ] whatever [ __ ] god damn it
did you get alfredo cam
oh
look at him how are we going to
repackage this and send it back to his
ass
well i mean obviously he's going to be
on his toes now so we might have to
lately we just got to get an airplane
and [ __ ] low
low flying into this backyard helicopter
just dump it on just dump it on the
ceiling and [ __ ] his roof up
you know what have you guys ever heard
kid leroy sing the man is incredible he
is so
talented in fact i didn't even think he
stole it the guy's got so much talent he
doesn't need to steal
it's probably just a coincidence
you were just
playing dumb earlier when you didn't
know how to pronounce his name and said
you've never heard of him before didn't
you see the back didn't you see my room
right here can you put that back up ian
yeah this is my room
this is my man cave back
that's what my man cave looks like i'm
just a huge fan bro
look how cool he is
bro he's got horns that's like rock and
roll as [ __ ] look at that he's savage
yeah he is his ass you know how many
savage moment compilations he has on
youtube dude unmatched yeah he's more
than pete davidson i'm a [ __ ] savage
you gotta do it
i'm gonna text oliver right now and just
say [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
it is kind of impressive that they got
that into that small box
i gotta say
yeah and it was sealed up in a very
because i was obviously suspicious yeah
but it was packaged in a very clean way
that it really didn't look um
didn't look that um
suspicious i mean i can't believe we got
to deal with this thing again
got [ __ ] silly zonk my dude my oliver
[ __ ] tree
what look at this thing
just that [ __ ] all over the place
all right how do we move on from this
i think we just got to burn it at this
point we got to do
well i guess you're going to surrender
what do you mean we by the way no we
have to fake burn it
you know what i mean we you ian by the
rules of the stroller this is on you now
you open the box oh hell no stop it you
you started this whole chain it's your
[ __ ] problem you gotta burn it dude
that i pay you to burn curses for me
what don't you understand about the
chain of command look i don't make the
stroller rules that's how it is
some of us are paid to burn
curses you know
bro we can't play it it's cursed
yeah we need to
we need chase station
how long we've been going man i don't
know how to cook go on after this we've
been going for an hour and a half that's
not enough such a mood killer that guy
the vibe is just off now man i can't get
over it
what the [ __ ] i dozed off i missed half
of that conversation
you slept through that yeah most of it
all right i actually got to go p and
then we'll talk about the joe rogan sub
drama because that [ __ ] is juicy and
good and exciting we do have to touch on
that there the joe rogan sub uh
subreddit is in full
civil war
it's pretty entertaining i don't know if
you can call it civil war i think it's
just full on revolt a full mutiny yeah
revolution a revolution is taking place
on on joe wrote okay i'm gonna go pee
i'll i'll be right back okay
i need to go bleach my body soul
easy
maybe we could just listen to a little
kid leroy while we wait for him to come
back i wish it wasn't copyrighted uh
yeah
cause that shit's
yeah
yeah you could post it on the uh
a street podcast twitter
[Music]
uh
somebody donated twenty dollars and said
zach i'm going to call my
can i say this no don't read that one
don't read that one
female genitalia zach i'm going to call
my female genitalia a piglet
why is that addressed to an exact
specific because i called my thing a hog
[Music]
okay so okay i just thought it was a
random weird question well shout out to
who who uh uh andy uh pack kaiser shout
out to andy we also donated 50
just a bit before that with with no
comment shout out to you andy you're a
legend that's 70 total to drop that
little nugget on we all got hogs and
piglets
[Laughter]
holly's asking us to keep the puppers
away from the curse yeah good call
from my understanding canines are immune
to curses that's one of their racial
traits yes yeah so i i think it's
actually okay they're they're immune to
a lot of stuff
send it to cobra taint
oh the whole stroller
yeah
i'm
messing with that you know what i'm
really upset about who who's gonna clean
up the [ __ ] stroller i was just
thinking i vacuumed this morning
it's like we shot that bit yesterday
right
[Music]
let's make ethan clean it up that's
gonna be the rest of the show just him
cleaning it up
uh
thanks for being amazing background
while studying for pa school finals pa
school
uh physician assistant
look at you
i've been there done that you got the
glasses on you're feeling extra yeah
yeah he's making money today
yeah
kells says i have coveted can i get some
prayers up in here the prayer is up for
kells everybody i hope you recover i
hope it's i hope it's a mild case stick
your fingers in the air everybody stick
your fungus in the air for kills thank
you thank you one like is x equals one
prayer dude that's right that's right
one sub equals one priority yo shout out
to the pod squad from um
canada i'm sorry if i'm saying that
wrong
none of that
none of that
i ain't having none of that none of that
hey
i appreciate you guys calling us a pod
squad
davey's really pushing for that
uh
oh mega awesome nerd aka avery or bud
says question if you did a looper
situation where the older you goes back
in time rather than getting your head
blown off by a gun by your younger self
instead it gets blown out by their mouth
is it considered incest still okay i
gotta reread that because i
i didn't understand this was a there's a
lot of layers to that i don't understand
this when you were doing a sexual dance
yeah
rather than getting your head blown out
by a gun by your younger self instead it
gets blown out by their mouth i see i
see what you're doing here is it
considered incest still so it's like a
[ __ ] thing he's basically asking is
it incest to give yourself a [ __ ]
your your past self a [ __ ] if you
go through a time machine of some kind
that's an existential crisis i do not
want to go to i mean yeah of course yeah
answer is of course i mean
[Music]
incest definition
um i'm back
sexual relationships between people
classed as being closely related to
too closely related to marry each other
well you know
i think people would say that you are
too closely related to yourself
to marry yourself you're not closely
related to yourself you are yourself
right so does that qualify as
no you can [ __ ] yourself it's fine okay
all right well there's your aunt avery
there you are ethan
has ruled
on that uh look up cobra tate on your
mom's house podcast yes uh i see a lot
of people saying uh that we were aware
that they he they had him on as a guest
and kind of goofed on him i i don't
think he was really
i don't think he got that he was being
goofed on i haven't seen
i haven't seen the episode so i don't
know exactly
if you watch the podcast you know they
kind of just goof on all these funny
characters
it's right nothing to prepare to like
compare to fresh and fit or whatever
right yeah that's weird well i'm back
everybody
welcome back thank you very much thank
you dan
let's talk about joe rogan
so as
roe vs wade
is uh about to be overturned as you guys
probably all heard
this preliminary
ruling got leaked
and those uh cultists
those [ __ ] christian cultists over
there on the supreme court
are ready to make women second-class
citizens
who don't have uh control over their own
bodies
terrific
it's actually horrific man that we have
to share
you know the the supreme court is
supposed to be apolitical did you guys
know that what a [ __ ] joke
yeah it's literally being ruled by
christian zealot cultists
and next they're going to be coming next
thing they're going to be doing if they
win the presidency
is they're going to be making abortion
illegal in the whole country
and they're going to be making gay
marriage illegal
oh you don't know what so i guess if
you're not american well roe versus wade
is what's referred to as a super
precedent
it was a court case that happened long
long ago like 50 years
in the 70s and the result of this court
case that was heard by the supreme court
was that
uh abortion became a right of all
women in the country that couldn't be
infringed on by states
it was considered a super
precedent which means it was like
basically settled law
well what happened was that when trump
became president
one of his campaign promises was that he
was going to pack
the court with uh there's this there's
this group called the federalists
which their whole society the federal
society their whole purpose funny you
talk about secret societies well there
you got the federal society peckin
it ruled that uh
it ruled that constitution of the united
states protects a pregnant woman's
liberty to choose to have an abortion
without excessive government
restrictions
so
part of his campaign promises
trump
worked with the federalist society who
basically recommends
the and and
works through the system these
uh
fringe lunatic psychotic
judges that are basically plants from
the gilead
to literally rig and over
over run our
our government
and you know what's crazy about this is
that only
only 30 percent of the country's
population actually is
pro-life as they call it aka anti-woman
i think i mean pro-life is a really nice
euphemism for saying anti-woman
because if they were actually pro-life
then you would have more funding for
after school programs for school lunches
for
orphanages for daycare for maternity
leave if they were actually pro-life
they would actually care about the kid
when it's born but they don't
it's not pro-life it's about controlling
women they hate women they want to
control them
they have a lot in common with taint
with uh
cobra taint
although cobra thing is definitely
pro-abortion
let's be frank
for himself
i mean that's the case i mean
isn't it unknown thing that trump has
had
dude trump i was gonna say trump trump's
had more abortions than he has than he
[ __ ] plays golf in a month maybe
that's just rumors but i mean it's a
rumor that's easy to believe for sure
did trump be doing out abortions like
brunch
trust me
the fact that he convinced any portion
of this country that he actually cares
about christianity or family values is
the biggest [ __ ] laughable con that
i've ever even heard of in my life it is
not confirmed but he
has been accused of i don't know if
that's the right word but you know
it's been put forward that he himself
has paid for eight abortions over
eight yes eight and supposedly made them
sign ndas right of course well you know
that's his thing eight abortions that's
funny because when they go like
it's funny when they talk about uh
restricting abortion
they their ideas like oh there's girls
walking around they're using abortions
as contraceptives
which isn't what happens abortion is
not an easy choice it's a traumatic it's
very very
emotional and very stressful
but ultimately it's up to the women but
it's funny because trump their guy
sounds like he does use it as
contraceptive that's eight times my
dudes
eight times that's awesome
yeah so
um these christian fundamentalist
cultists
are about to rule to overturn the super
president which removes
the
protection
of women to get an abortion without
excessive government restriction which
means
it'll become up to the state
to decide
so nothing's going to change here in
california and god bless and [ __ ] i'm
sorry everyone who lives in a red state
now especially women
affects men too but everyone living in a
red state
well nothing will change in california
for now
for now right until a republican wins
ron desantis or trump
again and then they make abortion
illegal in the whole country
and then that's when i consider leaving
i don't know
like that's just so [ __ ] insane and
then they're gonna make gay gay uh
marriage illegal again
and the craziest thing about it is that
again it's the vast majority controlling
the majority only 30 are in favor of
making abortion illegal 30 percent
[ __ ] crazy right
um
and you know when you make abortion
illegal people still seek it out it's
just very dangerous
or people get stuck in situations
they're just horrible
yeah there's been many studies about
that and
worldwide because you know there are
many countries where abortion is illegal
and always has been um the rates of
abortion seem to have
no correlation whatsoever to whether or
not it's illegal so like you said people
will do it regardless it's just how
dangerous it'll be because they have to
do it in a back alley or something so
you know what's crazy there's a lot of
countries that you would perceive as
more
religious or conservative where abortion
has it continues to be a protected right
israel for example abortion is
is uh
is a right that people enjoy and this is
a theocratic democracy
you know it's like even par for the
course of conservative religious
countries banning abortion is [ __ ]
nuts
because it it doesn't result in anything
good it's a net
[ __ ] terrible policy
yeah and the truth is rich people will
always have access to abortion
always just fly to california or
whatever fly to california fly to canada
or even in a state where it's illegal
you'll find someone to do it for you
you know they go on the hush hush
all those conservative senators knocking
up their mistresses they'll get
abortions they always do
and that [ __ ] happens all the time
um no it's the poor people
who were r-worded by a family member
or by some random person
who can afford to to
raise
a child who doesn't have the means to
raise a child who
was got pregnant like at 13 years old
these are the people that are going to
be forced to carry their children to
term
and the best part is they say they're
pro-life well when the kid's born they
they can [ __ ] die for all they care
because there's no there's no social uh
there's no social support for for kids
they got it all they got free lunches
they got they they don't want free
preschool they don't you don't even get
health insurance so where's the pro-life
there's no pro-life i mean have those
infants consider getting a second job
right they get on that rise and grind
there's gotta be something they can do
put them in a button factory or
something yeah there's got to be
something but you see what i'm saying
if you're pro-life then you take care of
the kids but you don't
you're not pro-life you're anti-woman
that's the difference
um so what does this have to do with joe
rogan
right so
so
basically
you guys know that joe rogan has just
garnered like a huge conservative
movement and specifically on a subreddit
one of the moderators
has been posting
a lot of like conservative memes and
[ __ ]
and so what happened here i gotta look
at
this
here's the main thread opening that
order
so yeah so here's the post that got
ended up getting
57
000 likes dude
that's monstrous
so the post is
so yesterday mod was posting right wing
political memes on the 2nd of may on the
3rd of may after conservative stack
supreme court directly attacks abortion
law now is when politics are off limit
for the month of may
and issuing temp bans for bringing up do
i have that right
hasn't this entire [ __ ] sub been
absolutely beside themselves about free
speech the last month but now is the
time to clamp down on things [ __ ]
pathetic with giant [ __ ] you guys are
and the title of the post is can we
please get a reply to this because it
seems pretty glaringly obvious why this
was done today especially ironic and the
very same mod is the one who's been
posting culture war memes lately
so as the news broke that the supreme
court is about to overturn
remove the right to abortion
um
the mods on joe rogan banned any
conversation of politics
and it is especially ironic because it's
like it's a free speech it's all that
matters
free speech
oh is this the mod responded
yeah the mod responded
so oh no the score is hidden
you know it's not good so first is
director of me i'll reply i'm not
american i barely know about roe versus
wade i am pro-choice liberal who can
still have a laugh at myself [ __ ] shut
it
if you look at their post history it is
a blatant lie they
are absolutely not should i even read
this i mean it's just them giving a lot
of excuses why it
had nothing to do with it it was just
coincidental that they banned politics
right as this news broke blah blah blah
blah
immediately i mean if you look at the
replies that's the more interesting
thing because he gets debunked heavily
before every big election he said he
banned politics midterms aren't for
another year you clown yeah what are you
talking about anyway it's pretty obvious
but i find it really interesting it's
like joe
these are your people man
you're part of the culture war now
and it's just been a full-on mutiny
on the subreddit that's been real
interesting
here's some images
um
what is this these are these are the
types of posts these are posts from that
mod who claims to be a pro-choice
library okay so the the mod who banned
political conversation
these are some of his supposed is it a
boy or girl well
we'll let the kindergarten teacher
decide cross-posting from social justice
in action
1500 points
oh it's just that one yeah he so he they
mass deleted uh most of their post
history um after they started to get
called out um but they missed this one
or somebody somebody else had posted the
screenshot of them oh that's a shame i
would have loved to have seen
oh similar subs to joe rogan oh this is
going to be good
let's see
jordan peterson louder with crowder
bro if you share our audience with
louder crowder you better just go erase
yourself
i can't even understand
being okay with that libertarian
conspiracy theories
oh no
it's us
i mean
these
you can't draw
conclusions from this um because
you know often times
people subscribe to a subreddit and then
never look at it for 10 years and so i
noticed i ran ours and there was
definitely some surprising ones in there
but not when you consider maybe the
audience that existed on your main
channel five or six years ago you know
what i mean
and um
not everybody
takes time to actually unsubscribe from
subreddits when they no longer
participate in them so but it is
you know interesting
i mean it's not even it's not i mean
it's not a surprise at all i mean his
audience has become extremely
reactionary over the last few years
that's where all the audience are it's
kind of nuts but like online if you want
views it seems like you got to go super
reactionary
to really get
get the people coming that's super
super [ __ ] unexpected but there it is
so where's all the chaos though because
there's a bunch of posts and i'm not
sure how to find them
oh just go to the just go to the
subreddit it's literally everything
that's what i'm trying to do
i got pulled out
uh
it's just showing okay hot
yeah i'm just trying to show anything
wait
i can't even open posts
oh wow
well
i just inhaled a piece of marijuana
joe discusses the possibility of the us
supreme court overturning roe vs wade is
this real
so apparently abortion's illegal again
right
what happened what here did you hear
what happened not just here no there's a
a leaked memo apparently some someone
leaked something
that says that they're going to overturn
roe v wade uh i don't know if it's real
everyone's already commenting on it as
if it is real i don't know if it is real
it is real dumb [ __ ] why don't you like
i mean this may have been recorded uh as
the news was breaking but apparently
what that means is that it's going to be
up to the states so people who live in
states where uh abortion is already you
know like blue states i don't think they
have a worry
but uh other states probably do you know
it's kind of
hey medical tourism yeah that's what's
gonna happen yeah it's gonna happen it's
it's it's [ __ ] weird man not if
you're broke you're not doing medical
tourism if you're broke as [ __ ]
right
that's and these are the people it's
going to affect
the people who already can't afford
are in a horrible position to have a
baby it's weird people telling other
people what they can and can't do with
their body is weird because
like texas is a weird law
no i shouldn't say a weird wall a
terrible law where it's six weeks
who the [ __ ] knows they're pregnant at
six weeks you just missed your period
like people i just found out i had
covered yeah exactly exactly it could
have been a baby ago and girls who have
irregular periods that happens all the
time i think i don't know i don't have a
vagina but uh that's what i hear i hear
it happens all the time and so
for the longest time you know people
have dealt with that and just sort of
live their life and take a pregnancy
test and
now you find out that you're pregnant
you literally have like a [ __ ] week
to find a place get an abortion if you
want to get an abortion make a decision
you have to make a decision you know
like but
the um the thing that i'm thinking of is
people that have like if something
happens to you like what if you get
raped
what if uh what if
you know anything like that or what if
uh you know some
like a family member molester i used to
have a bit about it but it's it yeah
it's a talking point like
how is it how should it be uh okay in
cases of rape that's like saying enough
venus is a living thing unless his dad
was an [ __ ] right right right right
baby's fault his dad was exactly right
how is it the baby's fault that
but what if it's your father or
something [ __ ] crazy sick
you know it's just
i just don't like you know i don't like
people telling other people what they
can and can't do but it gets weird when
the baby gets like six months old
nobody's aborting babies at six months
that's like one of the lamest talking
points
but anyway at least joe's actually seems
to be like understanding that and that's
the biggest paradox of these
conservatives they go uh
yeah rare joe w
at least he's consistent because these
conservatives they go we want we don't
want the government telling what we can
do
you must have that baby
well
you know joe
though in the last few years has
obviously swung
further right or more towards you know
mainline
republican sort of talking points that
he's espousing on his show all the time
for a long time most people would
probably uh
define joe rogan as a libertarian and
though you know we make jokes about
libertarians on the show a lot um
something i will say about libertarians
is
generally libertarians are uh pro-choice
so
right because it's totally surprised
that if your opinion is get the
government out of everything then right
at least be consistent for christ's sake
so that may be a vestige of the old joe
uh
i don't know if they i don't know if
they purge i don't see any posts about
those uh they definitely purged um i
don't see anything i sent a couple that
i found
that were
popping off yesterday
i mean you saw this one yesterday right
aren't you joe rogan yes and this
subreddit is about the joe rogan podcast
yes and this podcast discusses politics
and has a lot of political guess yes so
can we discuss politics no politics is
banned
of course
i mean joe is literally talking about
this topic on his most recent episode
but you are not allowed to talk about it
on the subreddit
i mean it shouldn't be surprising
all of the
conservative uh
subreddits are by far
the most sensor happy i mean
the donald is gone now but yeah but dude
you if you could you were you had to be
pro donald to be there yeah they would
literally ban you for anything even even
if you were a donald trump supporter and
you expressed a modicum of skepticism
about anything instant ban and that's
the case with uh just the generic our
conservative subreddit that exists as
well they ban
for anything and everything instantly um
but you know screech about free speech
endlessly so but this is honestly this
is why i hate these [ __ ]
pseudo-christian conservatives because
i mean it's not the first i'm not the
first one to observe it but they really
are just [ __ ] massive glaring
hypocritic [ __ ] psychos i mean most
these guys probably get abortions anyway
and they're just doing i don't it's just
a culture war it's just a means to an
end for them it's just a way for them to
get in power i think the people on the
on the supreme court are actually like
deep cultists who believe that abortion
is murder or something like that
this new set of conservative justices
are pretty hard line yeah
and they're young too boy so they're
going to be there for a long [ __ ]
time for a while
you like beer senate do you like
abortion senator
anyway that's good that joe at least is
saying the right thing
we drank beer
um
family causes airport stampede oh what
the [ __ ] bro
the swedish church is pro-abortion there
you go right love
yeah i just want to start maybe a little
bit of uh
different because i mean all
christianity isn't technically bad it's
like the typical american one though
who's who has like bad takes on
everything but the swedish church for
example is for abortion and all this
kind of stuff you probably don't even
know they probably don't even little
kids there yeah i mean christianity is
not a monolith by any means there's tons
of denominations and they all have
varying degrees of you know
uh
conservatives jesus was a good dude he
was a way ahead of his time super
progressive had a lot of good ideas but
you all [ __ ] aren't whatever you're
doing now ain't got nothing to do with
jesus
oh jesus
and every time i say something like this
i always get people saying like oh the
swedish church sucks blah blah blah i'm
not saying it's good or anything i just
want to add that it's interesting it's
progressive on that particular issue
yeah yes exactly i'm healed in the name
of jesus this happened in israel and boy
this was some dumb ass [ __ ]
you got to be so dumb to do this a
family in israel
oh my god american family yeah an
american family
set off a bomb scare at israeli's main
airport when they showed security
inspectors an unexploded shell they
found while visiting israel
these [ __ ] lunatics thought it'd be a
good idea
to bring
this on a plane
as a souvenir
the israel authority said a man was
hospitalized with injuries sustained
from fleeing over the baggage carousel
airport authorities said the family was
allowed to board their flight after
security staff declared all clear man
how dumb can you be you're too dumb to
live
i think we need to incinerate that whole
family they're too dumb to live we can't
allow it
and it's like
i mean that's a terrible idea anywhere
in israel in particular where they are
so on edge about you know terrorist
attacks and everything uh you know
trying to bring an unexploded [ __ ]
artillery shell what the [ __ ] with you
is uh you don't need anyone to tell you
not to do that
you just we kind of get rid of them we
need a big and certain incinerator too
dumb to live
here's the video
well yeah there's a lot of terrorism
going on in israel so when they hear
something people really you know have a
reason to panic
[Music]
[Applause]
oops
just why why did you this guy don't give
a [ __ ]
why did you do it this guy's chills out
around the line he's like peace
moses just i just part this [ __ ] like
moses
i'm going straight to my gate
look at this [ __ ] y'all
[Music]
man there gotta be some kind of
punishment for being that dumb i don't
know
well i imagine he said they were allowed
to fly go home on the flight what yeah
it said the airport authority said the
family was allowed to board their flight
after security staff cleared it declared
it was all clear
they just got on went home like nothing
yes they're too dumb to live i'm telling
you these people that can't be we can't
we can't keep letting them get away with
this i and it turns out
actually the dad who who uh
packed the unexploded bomb he's actually
uh a favorite to be the next supreme
court justice oh awesome yeah so there
you go that that that qualifies him
that reminds when we were kids my sister
brought fireworks to the airport because
we're going to florida for fourth of
july and she's just a kid she didn't
know my parents found it while we were
at the airport all of us having arab
names oh it was that post 9 11. yeah i
suppose 9 11 yeah it was uh scary but we
took him outside you got him out before
he got caught we got him off
in the parking lot he almost got sent to
guantanamo yeah i know
it was scary
holy [ __ ] what kind of fireworks were
there it was like the ones you buy from
like walmart like the big pack she just
took a bunch from there like from
walmart bro [ __ ] philadelphia or
detroit's crazy
they sell that [ __ ] at walmart you mean
the poppers are the ones you like you
like them and they they're like uh
oh you're just talking about sparklers
not sparkling no you put them on the
floor and then they shoot out like like
no it's legal there i think there you go
yeah in california they're not right
right oh interesting you gotta go
somewhere and buy them you guys like out
of state
there's like one place on the way to
lake arrowhead they're like off to the
road that used to sell them
i used to get them sometimes they're fun
yeah it's very it's illegal here so you
can't buy it right right think about
that
probably because my friends are like
shooting each other with them every
fourth of july but people still get them
you just have to drive out to some space
people get them i mean yeah considering
it's illegal you wouldn't know it on the
fourth of july yeah people go crazy
but if you could buy him in damn walmart
this whole city would burn down every
year oh yeah there's a big display like
every store not just walmart like target
everywhere i'd buy that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
dude
i say we burn it down
it's clearly not working out this
experiment is a failure let's burn it
down
and what better way than fourth of july
to do it
honestly
going full black gold on the show today
oh daley wire says that harry's is too
woke
um
you know it didn't occur to me maybe
that's the best story to cover when
harry's is sponsoring this episode
although it makes harry's look good i
mean i'm pro harry's yeah uh but
it feels a little
strong i'm pro heroes baby
wait they made jeremy
yeah it's
it's a good story we could talk about on
let's do it tomorrow leftovers
appropriate we can talk about tomorrow
yeah all right well
[Music]
anything else guys
uh no we're at two hours oh i didn't
talk about the kim k uh marilyn monroe
hair oh sure yeah that's a quick one
anyways
this is [ __ ] weird you guys it's very
weird kim kardashian wore one of marilyn
monroe's dresses at the met gala
the dress is from 1962.
marilyn monroe wore this dress to sing
happy birthday to jfk
um
kim also received an actual piece
of marilyn's hair
as a gift
um
the ripley's trunk
the please believe it or not museum in
orlando florida shared a video on their
instagram how'd they get her hair
they've had the dress i mean i know i
was wondering that too unless it was on
the dress
no it's like a fat lock what they give
her
yeah i'm not sure how they get her hair
someone tell me that right now is that
hair legally obtained i mean maybe they
zoomed her corpse
yeah when i straight up dug her up
well she's in the wall actually
um
when you i'm sure when she passed there
took hair cut some hair and just kind of
got sick
of one who's consent you can't just be
taking it dude it was this bodies the
60s man
you can't just be taking lots of hair
from a [ __ ] cadaver everybody's just
going up to the cough and cutting some
hair dude it was the 60s come on
i don't think that is that wild you ever
see the musical hair that came out in
the 60s yeah did they cut dead people no
they just stood there with their you
know
nude maybe she donated it before she
died that's the only thing nobody's
raiding her tomb for hair i can't
believe that it yeah no that is not
possible or she's buried it's not
possible
you think that
from ripley's we know they got it from
ripley's we're saying how the [ __ ] did
ripley's get a lock of her hair yeah
maybe they're just silly zonking her
dude and they're like haha this ain't
real okay well here's the video for my
dog man
here's the video
okay this is either really cool or a
little strange but that's who you're
doing business with right so
what is this that is marilyn's hair
i can't believe you're actually gonna
act impressed like that's a good gift
oh my god you didn't did you really give
her her corpse a buzz cut for me close
the trunk
don't sit there and act like that's a
nice gift you creep
so
that's really weird man that's awesome
oh my god i'm literally
stop it's hair it's human hair stop it
stop right now
i demand you stop right now
i see somebody say i think it's cool
well i think it's i think uh down with
it it it's way more creepy than it is
cool let's just be frank i don't know
i'd love it
why
do you want her finger clippings next
do you know what i mean here's her
actual pubic hairs
and some nail trimmings
i'm sure there's there's some people
that are getting another phone
i'm seeing mostly ears but i'm seeing
should we do a poll disgusting or cool i
don't know they auctioned like a creepy
or cool strand of john lennon's hair i
think a little a while back he's getting
well what are they gonna do clone them i
mean what the [ __ ] hair
cool what do you need a hair disgusting
cool or disgusting are those the options
yeah cool or gross is getting a chunk of
her hair cool or just i think the pull
is a little confusing but it's okay oh
my god yeah it's kind of confusing
honestly
is getting a chunk of her hair cool
disgusting
i think we need a third option confusing
paul
okay well we got 70 percent disgusting
so thank you disgusting that's a lot of
people who think it's cool
it's close to a third
yeah well down
that's the same amount of people that
support a ban on abortion
that should put in perspective
disgusting
um i just is she pretending to be stoked
or she's stuck
and i channel her
eat it kim prove how much you like it by
eating it absorb her power this is so
cool
what are you gonna do with this good
vibe wow
this is sleeping with me every night
sorry babe
oh boy
i don't like it i don't like the whole
presentation
i don't like the reception
i don't like anything about it
and i tell you if i die and one of you
[ __ ] come for my hair i will curse
you don't worry i already got it yeah
okay if one of y'all come to my tomb
and try to exhume some of my beautiful
locks
i will curse you for all eternity
hey i don't know nothing about nobody
hey you want some hair how about a fist
hey i heard you like hair
get a mouth full of my ass hair
garbage
we got some amaranth there
that's true actually wait there's hair
in there yeah that was probably one part
of the deal in the fart
right a fart and a hair fart in the hair
yeah it's a twofer
well she's alive
i come to ripley's museum believe it or
not
[Music]
and now you too you've given me human
hair
usually i go through great lengths to
dispose of human hair that's evidence
where i come from
and now you come to me with human hair
what do i gotta throw this out for you
what am i here garbage man
you just give me your trash to throw it
out there
if you want a piece of hair
eat some rabbit cubbies
i don't know nothing about nobody
hey ripley's believe it or not i don't
know i don't know if i believe it or not
i got no answer
who's asking
believe it or not who's asking
oh look at my hair
look at my hair
listen marilyn she's a sweet girl what
do i need her hair for you
i'm gonna take this pair i'm gonna put
this in my fleshlight
i'm gonna take this hair and put it in
my fleshlight cubbies
you give me a piece of hair i'm a cloner
you know what i mean and i'm gonna put
her into webcam slavery copyish
bottom line is you cannot be trusted
the bottom line is you gonna trust me
with this hair
i'm a cloner make a whole webcam
industry
i'll be a trillionaire
you see marilyn monroe doing a webcam
you don't pay for that
[Music]
i'll tell you what
how about y'all take a trip out on the
lake with me if you think this ain't so
entertaining
[Music]
gobbly go
all right stop
god damn it
okay this is really cool or a little
strange but that's who you're doing
business with right so
what is this is kim just so she has
everything that she needs like
freak oddities to get her kicks hey kim
i got you something it's a hair from
from adolf hitler's [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
isn't that [ __ ] amazing
oh my god i love it
hey kim here's a hair from
hey joseph stalin's left nut here how
about that pretty [ __ ] cool huh
[Music]
hey kim we got you a present
i got you the fingernail clippings of
genghis khan
now go ahead and cook it in your eggs
because what the [ __ ] else you're gonna
do with fingernail clippings
what is this
that's what's actually in the thing that
she's
oh that's the view of it that's the hair
yeah
a generous helping of hair they didn't
skimp her on that hair no no i'll take
an extra helping of hair
i want that venti you know what i'm
saying that vente hair
please stop someone said
yeah posty's having a baby i saw that
that's great good for him
wait they're saying he's a dad but did
he
she's just pregnant i think she's just
pregnant yeah
that's awesome good for him man i love
being a dad it's great it's the best
thing
really is
i'm gonna have to get him a piece of uh
to celebrate i'll be getting you a piece
of abraham lincoln's left [ __ ] nut
sack here guppies
it's an important part of history
[Music]
i heard you're a fan of music post
malone
i got you elvis presley's nipple here
to add to your collection
[Music]
thank me later
hey post malone
i heard you like music
you know i sat my chair back up because
i thought you were done but if we're
still doing this [ __ ] can i
i got you a piece of george harrison's
[ __ ] i got you a petrified piece of
george harrison's [ __ ]
keep it away from water cabeesh
she can end it
[ __ ] it i'm done
[Music]
you